Okay, so March 2023, picking up where we're left off, shifted bearish.
Unfortunately, this is a shift bullish.
This is also a shift bullish.
Thursday 2nd of March, bullish.
I think we may have missed a trade here.
Bearish, shift bullish. Long continuation from here. I'll say so, right?
Should get some decent rest reward plays as well, to be honest with you.
Thank you.
a lot.
a lot. a lot. a lot of people are going to be happy to have a good day.
We do have news to come out.
A couple of hours, should be up to hold for news, even if we get it to break
even.
Ah, no, have a look.
I'm not trying to get in again, because we do have a news at 5.
Don't really get much from news to us. So, reversal.
See what we've got here then, shall we?
Let's pull back.
I couldn't trade that.
A lot of people are going to be happy to have a good day.
Have a losing streak here.
That would be a low continuation.
Nope.
Technically now.
Cool.
Have an internal shift now, sweep of those age of low by any chance.
We do sweep them.
NFP.
No?
Not enough days in February.
Technically, it's not enough.
Okay, let's have a look here then, shall we?
It's a valid entry.
Something like that.
It's 9.
Oh, and also, yeah.
Some really, honestly, not icebergs action.
Genuinely, really not icebergs action.
That's a break, right?
Game over.
M5 inverse, there you go.
I'm not going to give the rest reward.
Set rates higher than that, it's an invalid trade.
The moment that price trades through your take profit level, it's obviously
invalidated.
Still bearish, I mean, still, still bullish.
Power at 10.
8.5.
We are on a four trade.
Let's go down.
[ Silence ]
It's an intern, power is about to speak, and that's power.
What is that price action?
[ Silence ]
It's a pretty large entry point, probably will refine it.
It's 20 pips, which is huge.
We'll bring it up to this in a minute, probably refine it as well.
It's still a large bit, still a large stop size, still a one to seven.
It's smaller, stop size, and out.
It's probably going to respect that, no.
That's so stupid.
It's LFP, obviously, because the first Friday in March was after the 28 days in
Feb.
Well, that's my fault, but I wouldn't say I'm at fault.
But yeah, this is what it is.
It's around like a five-trade losing streak at the moment, maybe more.
Not going great in March.
But sure, I'm taking all my losses in this bright look.
[ Silence ]
Try to still exchange a character phase.
I'm getting more aware that that was NFP, to be honest with you.
But we move.
Finally, we can remove ourselves from this trading range.
It's still not a great trading range.
[ Silence ]
Closed door, 30 emergency meeting.
President Biden speech and banking system.
Well, that's interesting, isn't it?
That's also happening at 9am, which is now.
But the problem is, no one knows what's going to be said in that.
Oh, that's not true.
And the Fed emergency meeting, like no one knows what's happening in that
meeting.
Wait a minute.
Time to push everything back an hour.
[ Silence ]
I'm about 5% so far from March.
But the thing is, is all it takes is one trade.
When you're in a drawdown like this, that's what keeps you going.
Like when you're in a drawdown, maybe four trades in a row, five trades in a
row, six trades in a row, right?
Which is uncommon, but you just remind yourself likely.
It's one trade.
[ Silence ]
That's the truth.
One trade.
And you're back.
That's why I personally like the whole higher risk to reward game.
This is one trade.
That's why you have to keep telling yourself to follow your plan as well,
because just me I've been there, I've been in drawdown periods.
And you start to doubt and stuff like that, you doubt your edge, blah, blah,
blah.
And then, you know, have to remind yourself that it's just one trade.
[ Silence ]
That's the time 445/14.
Okay, we do have news, but that news is later on.
We'll play out.
[ Silence ]
Execute news.
It's even one of them, so we're going to be break-even.
That's what I mean.
The last, I think it was 2024 I was talking about in a scenario where you're in
a trade.
And prices, you know, down here.
You can afford to move your stops to break-even when you have a news event like
this.
Instead of closing it.
Or you can close it, right?
That's also a possibility.
Because the spike might bring you back up to here and then down to here.
Or it might bring you back up to here and then you end up taking a break-even,
that's fine.
But when you're just entering into a trade and you're kind of hovering around
this area
and here and then you've got the news, it might do that, but you're going to
get a bunch of slippage.
Or it might do, you know, that slip your break-even and you take a better slipp
age.
But you can afford to do that.
And that kind of brings me back to my entire point.
You're one trade-away.
You can go on a-you can go on a drought.
Your wind rate's terrible.
You start doubting things.
It's not working.
Especially when you're in the live market as well.
It's easier when you're back-testing.
When you're in the live market and you've been two weeks trading.
I haven't taken a wooden trade yet.
It gets to you.
You're going to sleep that night and you're thinking about it.
Like, "Have I lost my edge?"
"Something wrong with myself."
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
You're going to sleep that night.
And that's it.
And you're going to sleep that night.
And you're going to sleep.
A point of interest.
I mean...
I don't know what's called that protocol.
I'm selecting.
I'll sit there.
I'm going to sleep that night.